the soggy weather held off and the sun
even broke through today here in london
as president trump kicked off his
three-day state visit
to one of america's oldest and strongest
allies
well the pomp and circumstance that only
the british monarchy can summon
was truly a sight to behold and the fact
that things went
so smoothly clearly irritated the media
elites at home and abroad
the occasion obviously involves a lot of
tradition
which is interesting for a president who
is i think it's fair to say anything but
traditional so much of any state visit
is pomp and ceremony and let's be honest
this that is what president trump likes
so much of this trip is in the pictures
it's not
insignificant for president trump in
many ways you might think
his best bet is to say very little and
just allow the pictures to speak for
themselves
well indeed many anti-trump media elites
they seemed disappointed that the
protests today and we were out and about
were so tiny it'll be very interesting
to see
just how large the protests are tomorrow
that are scheduled tomorrow don't forget
the president has a series of events
with prime minister theresa may that is
the day when we expect the protest
you know that there is a whole load of
protests planned
and that's going to probably come
tomorrow the protests not huge today
they're expected to be bigger tomorrow
president so far
it seems has avoided seeing protests
although tomorrow baby trump blimp is
making another appearance between 9 00
a.m
and 11 a.m local time so tomorrow it's
like christmas for them
today not so much well and of course the
lazy's in the lame stream media they
love sucking up to any trump critic on
foreign soil
and they did the same remember to reagan
in the 80s and
bush in the early 2000s and london mayor
city khan
was fed for writing an op-ed
welcoming the president this way donald
trump is just one of the most egregious
examples of a growing global threat
the far right is on the rise around the
world threatening our hard-won rights
and freedoms he wrote now
sadiq khan is a man who was at the time
an
influential member of parliament when
chinese president xi jinping came
to visit london uh not a peep from sadiq
khan
about xi jinping and let's president xi
only has what about a million muslims
in internment camps he oppresses
christians
and he jails dissidents and by the way
the 20th anniversary
of tiananmen square is today
but trump's the global threat for this
guy
oh my gosh trump is not just here
to have a fancy dinner as he did tonight
at buckingham palace
he's here to mark the 75th anniversary
of the d-day landing
and our enduring alliance there are
other close allies come in for the
commemorations they're not getting a
state uh
visit a state uh banquet costing
millions of pounds we're gonna have good
relations with
the usa but i don't think we should be
rolling out the red carpet
some of the things donald trump has done
over the last two three years
londoners find abort and offensive
well when someone strikes him trump hits
back
even when it may be considered a
diplomatic no no to do so
and as he landed in the uk the president
tweeted
sadiq khan who by all accounts has done
a terrible job as mayor of london
has been foolishly nasty to the visiting
president of the united states
by far the most important ally of the
united kingdom he's a stone cold loser
who should focus on
crime in london not me well the media
and the left feigned total
outrage president trump clearly
sent that tweet just seconds before air
force one touched down
at the airport knowing that it would
cause an enormous firestorm
unless president trump is kept very busy
during his
his visit he will not stay away
from twitter but of course this
president is always a great disrupter
and he wasted no time
disrupting the situation here president
united states goes to
england and before landing insults and
attacks one of the key leaders of that
country
but jeremy hunt the outgoing foreign
secretary under theresa may
hit the pettiness and the
shortsightedness
of the opposition party figures here
it's totally inappropriate for the
labour party to be
boycotting this incredibly important
visit this is the president of the
united states we're celebrating the
the d-day landings when we had a million
american servicemen
stationed in the uk willing to risk
their lives
for our liberty uh for democracy for our
values
and i think that this should be above
party politics so i think it's
absolutely disgraceful yeah jeremy
corbyn the labor leader is actually not
only did he not go to the dinner tonight
at buckingham palace
but he's going to take part in
tomorrow's protest so he's joining
the anti-trump and i would say in many
ways anti-american protests here in
britain
classy but england let's face it it's
such a beautiful place it's a special
place for americans for so many reasons
but watching the economy here the brexit
politics and the turmoil
i have to say it makes me appreciate our
system of government here
in the united states even with all of
its flaws you know why
because it's responsive compared to the
system of government here
much more responsive to the will of the
people
think about this over the past two years
the dominant parties in the uk
including the conservatives they tried
to sweep the concerns of the
working-class people under the rug
well and how did that work out for them
well an enfeebled teresa may
couldn't get a real brexit done despite
that referendum mandate from her people
so now she's done and meanwhile nigel
faraz's of raj's brexit party formed
just two months ago
was the top vote getter in british eu
elections
the timing of trump's appearance here
with all of the regal trappings
could not have come at a better time
it's a reminder of what's possible when
leaders heed the call
of their people trump alone has stood
against the tide of climate hysteria
burden tax burden some taxes and
regulations and
unresponsive international bureaucracies
he's supporting brexit not because he
wants to gratuitously meddle in the
british
people's affairs but because he knows an
independent britain truly independent
will be a better trading partner with
the u.s
and in the end it will lead to a
stronger america
a stronger britain and a stronger
alliance
and i got to tell you outside of the big
cities like london new york et cetera
people like the fact that trump is
mixing it up
he's refusing to be intimidated by the
so-called experts
because i think they've had enough of
all these smooth talking people
who screwed things up for the
working-class people in the first place
and mayor sadiq khan and others well
they prefer a docile american president
who nods an agreement when the u.s is
getting the short end of the stick
well that ain't trump and those days are
not coming back anytime
soon and there's a lesson for the uk in
the world to learn from the trump
approach
even though they might not want to admit
it he promised to make america great
again
and the country responded our economy is
now the envy of the world
and just look at steel manufacturing our
steel companies
were ravaged by chinese dumping
practices but trump fought back and said
no more
now many are revived and beginning to
thrive again
yet here in britain their last major
steel company is about to go out of
business
think about this a central nato power
will no longer be
capable of producing its own steel
oh no worries mate because the experts
say it will work out just fine
well it will when you fight back and
rebuild your own industries
it may be only june 3rd but it feels a
lot like july 4th here in england
trump is reminding our cousins that a
nation that is not truly sovereign and
free
won't be a nation for long true strength
and broad-based prosperity will only
come to a nation
that is independent and sovereign
and for those who bristle at trump's
rashness i say get over it
the resistance won't admit it but he's
getting results for the people
back home and if britain rejects the
false promise of globalism and listens
to their people
they can be great again too and that's
the angle